work on it and change it it can
manifest in different ways it may not be
in cheating but it may not it may be in
different areas and work in other
relationships they may be just dodgy in
however they approach different things
it shall send it to you in the dms i got
you um i just found it uh no because the
the thing is like so i asked my dad i
was like dad do people change
and he said to me this is my dad's
wisest person i know i swear to god he
knows everything about everything and he
goes
yes
they get worse over time
and he said so anything that you see
like at a young person like i swear it
is going to get worse it does not get
better
and because you can't cha like okay i
used to drink i don't i don't drink
anymore but there's always gonna be a
part of me that wants to drink and
that's never gonna go away
and so any guy that dates me like he he
knows there might be a chance that i'm
going to want to drink again because
that is what i used to do it's just like
yeah watching this uh
netflix series um it's called the i'm a
killer and so
this guy killed somebody he may say like
oh
i
um changed my life gave my life to
christ but that that instinct
it may be suppressed it may be in the
back of his mind but it's still there
you can't forget who who you were and
what you've done is still going to be
there and
it's going to affect you in some type of
way not saying that you're going to do
it again but they're still there
but you'll probably do it well i would
say that what i was saying earlier is i
100 agree with what you're saying if
you're promiscuous in your past you're
more likely to be promiscuous in the
future
my problem is like
with promiscuity as you said women are
great pretenders and they fool mr beta
male
how does these men who often say are
cool i want a woman who's got less
bodies than ten how do they even find
this is my point
are you saying like oh
i'm saying most women
are bigger hoes than you'd think yeah
because why
why
why should a woman not be sexual i don't
understand like the reason is
if you if you have the desire to get
married and to be with that one person
you're essentially making it harder on
yourself to
physically be like okay i'm going to be
with this person forget about all these
other dudes because there's things like
alpha we're doing where you have this
dude that just
rocked your world just change your life
and you can never get him out of your
brain
because of all the partners you've been
with and then you have just areas where
if you slept with all these dudes your
ability to is a parabon parabon with
your husband is going to be hard because
you've just freely given yourself to all
these other dudes to where when it comes
to your husband it's going to be like
yeah i love him but he doesn't do this
this this like this person did that
person that person did so it's like you
have all these bits and pieces of these
other dudes that just do men not have
the same thing
not in the same way women do because
it's like weird men can love multiple
women at the same time
so it's kind of like if if a guy has an
ex-girlfriend it's weird i talked to i
talked to this pickup artist like um i
went to a pickup artist boot camp this
dude so good with women like literally
slept with like three girls in three
days like whatever and he told me he's
like yeah the girls after me they always
get seem to get married after like i
sleep with them and he's like i still
get mad i'm like do you want them i'm
like he's like no
i'm good i just and it's because men
release a hormone that makes them like
territorial so men can love multiple
women on the same time because that's
natural to them there was 17 women
reproducing for every one guy where
women could only love one man because
and it has to be the best that she can
do because typically you you were with
the strongest guy otherwise another guy
would kill him and take you with and
kill your kids yeah so i think even like
the way we're designed reproductively
like we can impregnate multiple women
easily but you get pregnant once and
you're like out of the game for like a
while
if that makes sense and then also it's
like um the whole
lock and key
analogy where a cheap lock can be
occupied by any key however a master
lock can only be opened by wonky so it's
the idea that
whatever's behind the lock is precious
and needs to be
withheld at all costs and if it's given
out freely then it loses value and the
key that can open many locks is also
more valuable yeah
yeah because men i don't think most
girls think that like men are sleeping
around all the time but guys have to
work
men have to work really hard to be able
to get girls they have to figure out
money they have to go to the gym where
we're just 15 14 and guys start hitting
on us that's true and and so it's
it's not impressive to sleep with a lot
of guys and it actually repulses them
because historically they had to ensure
paternity so they had to say i want to
make sure that kid is mine and i'm not
passing on my resources to some some a
kid that's not mine so that's why
they're biologically predispositioned to
like pure women
for relationships they'll screw anything
but some of the obsessions with teens
because they appeal i would i wouldn't
say what do you mean obsession with
teens because most most guys i know like
like young women how how young as young
as as is legal that's legal yes it's a
bit mad still um they're obsessed with
them i think they're obsessed with the
idea of the purity in them like if they
were
if they were 20 and still like that oh
they would go for that but it's just the
idea of like they're still pure they
still they don't
i can conquer it there can be no other
father it will only be mine yeah yeah
pretty much
yeah and and so men value youth
fertility
and beauty
and so the younger you are the more you
have of that right okay because you know
men aren't lining up to date 50 year
olds so at some point it goes away
unfortunate
the the modern woman demonizes anything
that is uh
that detriment to her so for example as
us as men when we're young we realize
that
all right when you're like 16 you
realize the local drug dealer who's like
19 will pull up in a voxel course will
take the sexiest girl of the year and
you just have to take it because you're
young and that's it and that's just the
game is the game
you see women when they hit
like say touching 30 they'll go out to
clubs and they'll say
why is everyone in here a kid or they'll
start demonizing men of their age who
are dating 23 year olds like oh why
can't you get a woman your age and they
don't accept that power dividers now
because okay once you see this you can't
really unsee it every time men have a
standard women shame them for it body
count yeah so every time so the things
that men value they're shamed for
valuing
so so for example if a guy says i want a
young girl i want her to be in shape i
want no kids
they're they're saying you're fat phobic
you're slut-shaming
but girls can go on a public platform
and say i deserve this this this and
this and nobody bouts and i
i like i deserve a guy that treats me
right i deserve a guy
that makes this amount of money i
deserve a guy that's this tall and no
one will say anything
okay where do you think that comes from
i just think society is geared towards
women we make 70 to 80 percent of
consumer buying decisions so i just
think everything in the media is for
women except this channel like the video
i think i think part of it is
women are sold this narrative from such
a young age that you can be whatever you
want and it doesn't matter so like for
example body positivity